for the estimated 25 of the us workforce
who have seen their work shift to be
fully remote or for those leaving jobs
in search of more fully remote work
there's a new trend that could double
your salary and it's simple work two or
sometimes more full-time remote jobs at
once and in secret my household income
was probably 300 400 000 somewhere there
before and now we're over a million
people think of those numbers as really
big numbers it's not possible i think
this is a mindset thing
in a survey published in october of 2021
nearly 40 percent of remote workers
admitted to having two full-time jobs
this movement has been dubbed
overemployment and an entire community
has popped up to help navigate their
secret double lives with advice like
what you can use to be on two zoom calls
at the same time or how you can avoid
burnout by being mediocre proponents
believe that for some it can unlock both
more money and less stress but for both
employers and employees can multiple
remote jobs be a sustainable part of our
future of work
trends and multiple full-time employment
of course only apply to certain
industries
there are of course some industries like
healthcare and restaurants and travel
that simply can't be remote but with the
exception of those many have the ability
to work from home client-facing roles or
jobs that require in-person attendance
can't be done simultaneously unless they
operate in completely different hours of
the day but that leaves a lot of room
for knowledge workers in sectors like
technology and finance people have
gotten a lot more efficient working from
home and so
that has reduced
the working day to some degree and has
probably allowed for especially software
developers for instance
to work another job perhaps because
they've saved on time recent research
found that 31 of tech professionals
admit to putting in just three to four
hours of work a day with one anonymous
facebook employee saying that they put
in less than one hour of work if you
don't factor in all the hours of
meetings a lot of people in o employee
community are in accounting finance
insurance sales obviously you know
software developers are kind of at the
forefront of the community and still is
the most remote friendly job just from a
supply and demand reason this is the
voice of isaac he runs the website
overemployed.com a site dedicated to
give resources and promote the idea of
working multiple full-time jobs and
being someone who himself claims to work
two jobs he has asked us to keep his
name voice and image anonymous
overemployed really the stem from me
trying i guess it out myself you know
talking to several different lawyers
looking at my employment contract and
seeking knowledge and and permission if
you will and then i haven't talked to a
family member i was just you know
chuckled at the idea because and said
that she knew many people that were
doing it and it's been the biggest open
secret out there i was like okay
for some it may be surprising to know
that what people like isaac are doing
doesn't necessarily violate any laws
generally speaking there's there's no
law that would prohibit an employee from
having two jobs at once uh at most it
can be a violation of an employer policy
there are some employers who have what
they call no moon lighting policies some
are a complete ban on outside employment
some say no outside employment that
interferes with your job duties or
conflicts with what you do for the
employer or with the employer's business
nevertheless those who have two jobs
often go to great lengths to hide that
fact i tend to have a very defined
structure on how i structure my days my
day is actually very busy being a dad
that's my number one priority and then i
still work in in kind of 90 minutes you
know sprints i call them for you know
three four of them throughout the day to
focus across you know one job or two job
uh job one or job two and and get what i
need to get done there one thing is
never mix the hardware if you will keep
it completely separated and stand alone
don't use your employer's property their
laptops computers printers paper
whatever it is to perform work for the
other employer
and don't ever lie about not having the
job because employers can you know fire
employees for dishonesty no matter what
it relates to some companies are
catching on to potential moonlighters
using tools like artificial intelligence
or productivity monitoring software that
can track employee engagement with
various tools like monitoring how much
your mouse is moving during the day
but even for these obstacles the
overemployed community has well
solutions and while technology can help
keep some of these over-employed workers
from legal issues they also need to be
aware of their own mental load
when you're thinking about two jobs and
when you're thinking about the
implications of having two jobs not just
in terms of responsibility but in terms
of the psychological load of having to
lie and having to hide i think it again
it depends on your unique situation it
depends on how hard it is for you to do
that especially when we know that
psychologically when you feel guilty
about something it's like the pressure
of being found out is can almost be
excruciating this is raha f harfouche a
digital anthropologist and researcher
who recently wrote a book on hustle
culture and burnout we're playing all of
this over employment stuff on the
backdrop of a global pandemic of opening
and closing borders we're already pretty
stressed
many of us are already pretty stressed
managing enough uncertainty so if that's
not your personality adding yet another
giant bundle of uncertainty that could
have legal financial reputational
consequences it would just be something
that i would advise that a person would
really think through uh because you know
the all the money that you could earn if
it ends up tanking your reputation in
industry or having legal consequences
and stressing you out so you can't even
enjoy your time off those are the hidden
costs that we need to take a look at i
think this is a misconception that
people have that that you know if you do
multiple jobs you must be overworking
you don't have to if you're productive
and thoughtful about how you allocate
your time with deep focus work etc as
isaac explains having two jobs at least
in his experience has actually reduced
the stress around his work i haven't
found it stressful but to each your own
one of the nice side effects of virtual
remote work is you know with two jobs or
three jobs or whatever if you don't like
the meeting you don't have to go to it
see what happens to say decline i kind
of get the meeting notes you know if
that meeting was wasting your time it
wasn't adding to your bottom line
results that you're you're tasked to
produce
you can stay wide and i think a lot of
the over employer kind of leading
some of the charge and pushing back with
overworking that a lot of people with
one job are over compensating actually
and overworking because they worry about
their job and that's why they're the
ones that are like you know going to
meetings 12 hours a day back to back you
know it's a choice that this really
comes down to it's a choice of what you
do with your time
and taking that time back is a mindset
shift that is at the core of what the
proponents of overemployment believe
detach yourself from your job don't wrap
your identity into work
and strive to simply meet expectations
not exceed them in our work culture we
have the sociological phenomena called
work devotion which is a set of
behaviors that we all do that we've all
done that signal to our colleagues and
co-workers that we deserve our success
so what ends up happening is their sense
of self-worth becomes intrinsically
linked with how hard they work with the
type of job that they work and then it's
not even about the job that they have
it's about how hard they're working for
that job what we've actually been seeing
research-wise economically for years is
that people are working really hard
there are some people that are working
two and three jobs not over employment
just two to three jobs in the gig
economy part-time work and still are not
able to make ends meet and so for me i
think if you are going to do this and
separate your sense of self from your
job if that's what it takes for you to
say hey i am not my job title that maybe
i want to be present and joyful and
healthy and happy and have relationships
i think that's great and even if it is
possible to work two full-time remote
jobs it likely isn't going to be for
everyone but it does point to a larger
trend happening in work overall a
shifting perspective on our work life
balance
when the pandemic happened and lots of
people lost their jobs a lot of people
were slow to come back to their employer
or there was just this psychological
shift where they were rethinking the
type of work that they wanted and that
resulted in a labor shortage and so now
people have this power to
negotiate and sort of get the type of
work that they want
as the economy recovers workers have
used this new power to find better
working accommodations in a movement
that some have been calling the great
resignation we really saw this idea of
the great resignation start in the
middle of last year
and this was as unemployment benefits
started to kind of unwind and people
were going back to jobs that they had
before the pandemic but they realized
that the hours were very rigorous for
example or that the work was not
positioning them for the future that
they wanted we've moved away from
40 hours a week at your desk nine to
five and toward people having more
autonomy over
how they want to shape what their
careers look like long term and for some
in the overemployed community growing
your income the traditional fashion by
being promoted can look less attractive
for example according to glassdoor.com
the average total pay for a software
engineer is about 156 000 per year at
google and 166 000 per year at meta and
while senior software engineers make
significantly more money it still isn't
as much as having two more junior roles
if you have a full-time job you know you
are
you have one source of income and if
based on continuing economic disruptions
layoffs are becoming more and more
common across industries so does it make
sense for you to devote all of your time
and your extra time into one company
where one day you can come into the
office and suddenly it's like guess what
no more job this has just sort of opened
a door for people to
navigate employment in new ways but it
doesn't necessarily mean people
are going to be able to sustain two
three jobs at a time for many years
because as we mentioned burnout is a
real thing and even if you can do it for
a year or so it doesn't mean you can do
it you know once you've got children or
once you've got other responsibilities
that kind of take time out of your day i
think you're going to find that there
are people that are going to be engaging
in over-employment for very different
reasons in very different ways if
there's one thing that we can take away
from over employment it's this idea that
we have more control over our time than
we think there are things that we
believe to be true about working about
our day-to-day about our calendars about
our relationships with our teams and our
bosses that are the way they are because
we've never questioned them because
that's just how they've always been so
the more interesting thing to think
about is
how can i where can i do things a bit
differently where can i explore new
ideas or try new things or
test out new concepts and maybe by doing
that you'll start to shift and realize
that your work reality is whatever you
make it
you